quand je dis que j'ai pas envie que j'ai
pas envie là j'ai pas rater pour c'est
ce qu'on allait faire toute la journée
tu m'aimes tu me respectes une campagne
de prévention des violences dans les
relations amoureuses des jeunes âgés de
15 à 17 ans des adolescents concernés
par ce phénomène certains lycéens ont
participé à l'élaboration des vidéos et
des affiches dans mon entourage dans mes
amis qui sont en couple
je vois des parfois des attitudes qui
sont un peu un peu dégradantes un peu de
possession
vous même des applications qui vont un
peu trop loin basse déjà sept forcer
quelqu'un à faire quelque chose dont il
n'en a pas envie
par exemple bâle a forcé à avoir des
rapports sexuels
et ça c'est vraiment dans les cas
extrêmes mais même par exemple de
toucher une personne à des endroits par
exemple fin quand elle n'en a pas envie
les adolescents une population prise en
compte par le centre hubertine auclert
organisme rattaché à la région ile de
france spécialisée dans les expertises
sur l'égalité hommes femmes
sa présidente marie pierre bade réélu au
conseil régional a lancé cette campagne
on s'est rendu compte à la suite des
enquêtes que nous avons menées que nous
n'avions pas cette tranche d'âge de 15 à
18 ans on a bien vu qu'il y avait de
vrais soucis quand on les a interrogés
notamment sur le caractère un peu
violent de la façon dont ils
s'appréhende est dans leurs relations
des affiches ont été envoyés dans tous
les lycées d'île de france
les chefs d'établissement ont la
possibilité de contacter le centre
hubertine auclert pour demander une
formation du personnel afin d'aborder le
sujet avec les élèves
si vous voulez une relation sans
consentement c'est un peu comme les
épinards quoi basse et dégueulasse
[Musique]